[Music]
is nature a gigantic cat
and if so who strokes its back
may i introduce the brilliant nicola
tesla
the greatest inventor of the age if you
google nikola tesla you get 34 million
results
it's basically just four pictures beyond
that things get murky and more
imaginative
thomas alva edison you gotta like
oh tesla didn't see you there before i
now have the pleasure of introducing you
to a novel system of energy
alternate currents this will transform
the way the world works
it's perfect where you've been hiding
alternating current
is a waste of time impractical and
deadly
you live in your head doesn't everyone
you lack funding
mr tesla thinks i owe him money what was
it fifty thousand dollars
yes and morgan daughter of j pierpont
morgan
a woman like that can make all your
dreams come
true all my dreams are true you want
lemonade
you work at night in a secret laboratory
you
shoot lightnings from the earth to the
sky
time to rank the team wild cat and i've
become nothing but a mass of bloody
scratches
are you like being scratched if
[Music]
necessary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the world we are living in
is a dream that tesla dreamed first
[Music]
you